that is the claim actually uh not last
friday friday before when when i was
filling in for rush
well we spoke to rudy giuliani and he
mayor giuliani brought up that there
were huge
shocking issues with dominion and
smarmatic so it wasn't just sydney
powell
making this argument though she was the
only one making this argument
at the press conference so
here is sydney powell's grand claim
one of its most characteristic features
is its ability to flip
votes it can set and run an algorithm
that probably ran all over the country
to take a certain percentage of votes
from president trump and flip them to
president biden
which we might never have uncovered had
the votes for president trump
not been so overwhelming in so many of
these states
that it broke the algorithm that had
been plugged into the system
and that's what caused them to have to
shut down in the states they shut down
in so she's saying that you and we
remember this on election night for some
reason the vote counting stopped
just for and and then in some places it
continued even though it was continuing
behind closed doors illegally not the
way it was supposed to be done
why did that happen sidney powell said
it's happening because people were
electronically trying to steal the
election
and so many people voted for trump they
had to go in and fix it somehow
okay we don't we don't have evidence for
it we just
have the circumstances that sidney
powell is bringing up and we have her
claims and and i
should point out cindy powell has had a
real career she was an
assistant u.s attorney federal
prosecutor
she was the lawyer for mike flynn so
this is not
you know some lady sitting with tinfoil
a tinfoil hat on
now i don't know maybe she's gone
completely insane that's an allegation
against her
maybe she is maybe she hasn't maybe
she's a very serious lawyer and she
actually has the goods
we don't know she has been going on news
shows over the past
weekend to give greater detail on some
of her claims
this isn't a summary judgment motion
where we actually have to produce any
evidence now your typical lawsuit
you just file the statement of what the
charges are without any affidavits or
anything
what do you think they're going to fight
why the media is going about this is
absolutely ridiculous and unreasonable
to
expect us to put evidence in right now
although we are we know election issues
are on an expedited schedule
but i could wait a month to file the
fraud case and everybody would have to
undo their certifications because it's
so bad
but are you saying you're going to file
the same case in multiple jurisdictions
or in one jurisdiction
each one's a little bit different
depending on what happened in the state
the different manner and means and the
evidentiary aspects that support each
one
you know we've got different affidavits
from different witnesses in each of the
states
so they're going to be some differences
between them but they're going to be
claims that are
identical some of the legal claims are
going to be identical
for example in a number of states the
there were modifications to the machine
after the statutory cutoff date
that should invalidate every vote cast
on the machine
so she's sticking with her story and
she's giving
more examples though we haven't seen a
ton of hard evidence just yet
since these interviews the trump legal
team has distanced itself from sydney
powell they sent out a message last
night said sydney powell is practicing
law on her own
she's not a member of the trump legal
team she is also not a lawyer for the
president in his personal capacity
that was a memo that came out from rudy
giuliani and jenna ellis who are on the
trump legal team
now in the past president trump has
described sydney powell as a member of
the trump legal team
i don't know that sydney powell has ever
described herself as a member of the
trump legal team
i think she's described herself as a
supporter of the president but i haven't
seen her do it news shows have described
her as a member of the trump legal team
but again i don't know that she has
herself
now powell for her part has responded to
this statement
powell for some reason was kicked off of
twitter when all of this came out
so she couldn't defend herself on
twitter it's a little strange and powell
responds and says i understand today's
press release
i will continue to represent we the
people who had their votes for trump
and other republicans stolen by massive
fraud through dominion and smartmatic
and we'll be filing suit soon the chips
will fall where they may and we will
defend the foundations of this great
republic
hashtag kraken on steroids so
so sydney powell totally doubling down
and unless you think by the way
that the trump legal team is is totally
shocked
by what sydney powell was saying go back
to the the rush limbaugh show
not not you know three days ago not this
past friday but the friday before that
when i was filling in
rudy giuliani bringing up similar issues
maybe not with the same ferocity
maybe not with the same
grandiosity but he is bringing up the
same issues with dominion
and smartmatic i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts